notice that the uh
weapon has this curve you see
that's that's an energy line so as I
come around I want to lose contact I'm
going to keep contact come around and I
will be able
when I hit the the convex Apex of that
curve that's where I'm going to put my
Apex of my curve and that'll do the
displacing for me
okay so around
and I can be pretty straight but his
Vulcan is being displaced
you do it all early you see it's in the
way and I gotta move it and I gotta take
this angle over here so I would like for
you to feel just the the energy of his
of the curvature you you'll feel the yin
and that's where you feel that you
change to yawn so you'll feel it
it'll displace on its own without you
having to do anything drastic with your
hands okay try to
all right so he's gonna he's gonna go
around that and I'm gonna feel when whoa
right when I feel that displacement
thing
you're gonna feel the the energy of the
two weapons are gonna change and I'm
Gonna Keep it and now I have to hang it
whoa right when I feel this boom and you
see I have that
foreign
[Music]
okay
the one thing you can pay attention to
is he's coming in that shouldn't happen
we're now mismatched okay that there's
no there's no energy for me to get back
on the young side of this so he's gonna
do Yang here he's going to displace me
it's gonna take a lot of muscle for me
to do that so as a metric you can use
the fact that he's coming around going
sorry
he's coming around that our sword stayed
even this thing for most of it until I
decide to let him go by oh and that's
when I'm coming in okay
close the gap too early
so I'm coming around this time so I'm
coming around boom there he goes he's
coming back in I'm gonna be clear
okay notice that I'm still stuck on him
and what I'm doing is rotating the cross
around this way
here
we don't lose contact
so around four around two
very very small little flick
[Music]
[Laughter]
when do I flip right what I feel is
energy right when I feel is there it is
[Music]
just follow me in space
all of the in space
okay all right so just like if I uh
doing uh
just like uh
don't try okay so I'm gonna do an an IP
adhesion right so I'm going to get that
pressure there and then I'm going to be
able to move it got it
all that kind of stuff that I'm doing I
have to first before I can do that I
have to be sensitive to what is his
energy level so that I can get this
going
do you see and then as he relaxes and
tries to counter it becomes even harder
it becomes even harder to feel that so I
have to increase my sensitivity okay so
before you can do I keep Ken you have to
feel the yin yang shift so that this is
a drill in the yin yang shifting okay
and uh in other words as I come around I
don't have to really do anything with my
bulkhead it just sort of Falls in place
so you he'll go you see and he comes
back in and I don't have to do anything
because it's just fitting in those Yin
spaces
so same thing here I'll come around I I
don't have to do anything with my book
and it can just fall go
oh this is falling
can you say that and you're going like
this
so if you pay attention to my
moves all my moves are forward so as I'm
coming around and he defends
I'm just charging you see I'm just
charging someone
well that means I can't contest with his
weapon okay
so one more move for this so he's going
to come around I'm going to do again I'm
just fitting you see it fits
don't do stuff with your sword
foreign
[Music]
pull
boom boom
over my head
you can go lay
sorry
legs
or
listen to the pull on his Western
okay let's try